[Music]
so tesla rolled the new roadster 2.0 off
the back of a truck and unveiled all of
its ridiculous specs in november of 2017
world record acceleration world record
quarter mile time world record electric
range this looked like the new king of
performance sports cars so if you liked
it you could order a founder's edition
on the spot that day to be in the first
thousand you just have to wire transfer
the full price of the car to tesla
within 10 days 250 000 but now it's 2022
and that car is still not out yet and so
you just gave tesla a five-year
interest-free loan of a quarter million
dollars
now if you just put that exact same
quarter million into an investment that
actually earns you money like let's say
i don't know buying tesla stock with
that exact dollar amount on that same
day
then that would be worth more than four
million dollars today
electric cars have a problem right now
so first let me just say i firmly
believe electric cars are the future i
think a lot of people would agree with
that
but they're just that they're the future
not the present so 99 of the cars on the
road today are still gas cars but the
problem comes from how entirely
unpredictable electric car launches have
been for the past like half a decade to
the point where if you put your money
down for one of these things
you really don't know exactly what
you're going to be getting
or when you're going to be getting it
now a big part of this is the fact that
there are so many new companies trying
this like the car industry is mostly
huge old companies but tesla's success
has convinced a lot of people they can
spin up a new electric car company too
with their own little twist but the
thing is making new electric cars is
really difficult and really expensive
and starting a new electric car company
is even more difficult and even more
expensive so i present to you the
five-step guide for creating a new
electric car company today and see if
you can spot which one of these steps a
lot of these new startups are getting
stuck at so step one make a clever name
with a great idea for an electric
vehicle preferably something tesla
hasn't already done yet and make a
snazzy website to show off this cool
idea you have step two become a company
you know you're going to need an
enthusiastic ceo a fun company culture
maybe even poach some people from other
successful car companies and start
making this idea look very promising
step three build one prototype so this
is the key so you can you can build more
for bonus points but all you really got
to do is make one working version of
this new vehicle you know if not all the
high-tech features are working that's
fine you just got to demonstrate the
ability to build an electric vehicle
then step four you gotta take this
vehicle and use it to generate as much
money as possible parade it around to
generate attention show it off bring it
to car shows let the press try it and
you gotta put a pre-order button on your
website so people who like the idea can
give you a little interest-free loan but
more importantly you can use the number
of pre-orders to get big investors
interested in getting on board so you
look how much promise and interest the
idea has you wouldn't want to miss out
on an opportunity to invest in a next
big electric car company right then step
five
ship it
use the money you raised
build a factory
build the technology
become a car company
and ship it now spoiler alert
pretty much all these companies get to
step four but the gap between step four
and step five
is massive it's like that how to draw an
owl tutorial like step one draw two
circles step two draw the rest of the
owl but it's really hard you have all
these new companies coming up and making
all this interesting stuff but then not
getting to the last step and that gap
has created so much distrust and
confusion about what to expect when you
put your money down for something you
know it kind of reminds me of like
smartphone launches i've talked about
sony before you know when apple or
samsung announces a new phone it's on
stage and then two weeks later it's in
the stores you can buy it and then
sony's problem would be you know they'd
announce a new phone and it would be
kind of cool but then it wouldn't come
out for six months and so by the time it
actually did get released
all the hype was gone the interest was
gone people who were thinking about
spending that money on that would spend
it on other things and it would it would
just fall apart now people are willing
to wait a little bit longer in the car
industry but it's just getting kind of
ridiculous so i think my earliest
experience with this was with faraday
future some of you might have heard of
them cool name very interesting company
they nailed steps one and two and they
showed me a functional prototype five
years ago in 2017. it was super cool
they showed it to me on the ces show
floor and they drove people like me
around in it and even did a 0-60 in 2.39
seconds
[Music]
that is legit not bad right so they kind
of nailed step three so then they moved
on to try to generate as much money as
possible
you know for the factory and the
engineers and everything required to
ship the thing
and they've been stuck in this step ever
since you know they did allow pre-orders
which are still open by the way you can
still give faraday future one thousand
five hundred dollars to pre-order the
ff-91 and they even went public which
helped with capital so they've raised
enough money and they've put together
enough to be worth about two billion
dollars now
and that's still not nearly enough money
to have actually made the factory and
shipped anything will they ever get to
step five will they ever actually ship
an ff91
i remember another company called biten
they had a pretty cool prototype i also
saw them at ces this was about four
years ago and this again made a pretty
big splash i remember all the headlines
from the show awesome presentation their
site too is full of great ideas for a
pair of vehicles that are presented as
very realistic and very achievable they
managed to raise 1.2 billion dollars
from investors
but they've gone silent they haven't
tweeted in two years their website
hasn't changed since 2020 and they
certainly haven't shipped any cars and
then canoe is another one of these
companies they might ship something so
they were they were founded in 2017 by
some ex faraday future employees they
eventually got hyundai and kia to
announce they'd work with them on a new
electric vehicle platform they got
listed on the stock exchange and valued
at 2.4 billion dollars
now hyundai and kia look like they've
pulled out but you can still go to
canoe.com and pre-order one right now if
you really want to
but they haven't shipped anything yet
either then like a week and a half ago i
got an instagram ad for a company called
atlas motors that i'd never heard of
and out of morbid curiosity i clicked it
and it is kind of wild their home page
the home page immediately promises an
electric vehicle platform that will help
any company electrify their lineup and
then a quad motor pickup truck with up
to 500 miles of range that can charge up
in 15 minutes but the biggest brightest
button up at the top of their website is
the invest button so if you like the
idea that they've shown you enough you
can get in at the ground level of this
crowdfunding for what might be the next
big thing
apparently they're already worth nearly
a billion dollars so they say they're
going to be using the funds for
equipment and machinery and research and
development and administrative expenses
and
you know basically making a company but
when will atlas motors actually ship
anything
i i don't know that's a great question
and if you really want to see what a
failed blueprint of trying to get
through these five steps looks like look
at everything lordstown motors has ever
done so lordstown was founded in 2018
with this nice plan to make electric
pickup trucks so they'd have in-hub
motors in the wheels and they'd started
around 52 thousand dollars seemed like a
really cool truck nice idea they'd made
some nice pre-production models to
parade around and gather interest from
fans and potential investors you could
find a lordstown endurance truck at
almost every conceivable auto show which
is great for people pointing cameras at
it so they got to step three take
people's money and so they went over to
gm and bought an old plant from them
which got them interested enough that gm
decided to invest 75 million dollars in
this promising new company they went on
to open pre-orders and got over a
hundred thousand pre-orders and then
with all this momentum they went public
as a company and their evaluation soared
to over five billion dollars but then
unfortunately an investigation found
that most of these pre-orders were
fabricated
not real plus they allegedly paid a
company to place around a thousand
pre-orders sick
this company's pretty much been falling
apart ever since lordstown today is
somehow still worth hundreds of millions
of dollars
but i
don't think they're gonna be shipping
anything anytime soon but then the
latest startup that you might have seen
in the news was rivien now rivien looked
like they had all the promise in the
world because not only did they have a
really good idea the r1t and r1s
vehicles and not only did they have a
great presentation and a hungry target
demographic and a cool ceo but they
actually seem to be getting real money
together so they had a contract from
amazon they got investment from ford
they were getting billions and billions
of dollars together
and that seemed like they might be
getting enough to scrape together to
jump over to step five they might
finally leap to be able to ship these
new vehicles you know they got one of
those pre-production trucks out to our
studio here and i lived with it for two
days and i was very impressed i love the
thing enough to put in my own pre-order
it had all kinds of cool features
working software and honestly it's one
of my favorite evs i've driven to this
point but as you know it's easy to make
just one
it's easy to make just one but rivian's
got enough money so they had they could
do the r d they could build the factory
and they could finally start actually
shipping some of these slowly but
they're shipping some real units to real
users as we speak but even rivien has
had a bumpy road you know with all the
capital needed to start things up plus
the wrench of the pandemic and the
supply chain shortages being thrown into
things even they a bit underestimated
how much money they would need to make
these trucks for people so a few days
ago rivien decided to raise the price of
all their vehicles by around twelve to
fifteen thousand dollars and that
included all of the trucks that all
those people had already preserved so
they wouldn't honor the price of those
old pre-orders cue
massive amounts of backlash which
totally understandable the truck just
went from 70 something thousand to
nearly 100 grand but it must have been
more blowback than they were actually
expecting because rivien walked that
back like 24 hours later so there is
still a higher price for new orders if
you were to order today but they let all
the people who had those old pre-orders
in stay in at the low price and they
offered that low price back to people
who'd canceled if they could just
get back in line please so even rivien
isn't immune to all this chaos but they
have gotten the furthest in the
five-step process to the point where
they're now delivering cars and they've
promised i think they've projected 25
000 cars to be delivered this year
for context tesla delivered about a
million cars last year ford delivered
about four million cars last year so i
think all this highlights how hard it is
to get to
step five on the master plan but some of
you might be thinking wait okay what if
you're not a startup maybe you don't
need to go through the same five-step
process
but still even a lot of these more
established companies are treating their
new electric cars
like kickstarters
they might not just have to do the first
two steps so these days i do see some
volkswagen id4s i see some mustang mock
ease i see some ionics out there on the
road love to see it but then there's the
ford f-150 lightnings of the world which
they've definitely shown off they've
brought one to the studio here you can
pre-order one right now and they should
hopefully be starting to ship in a few
months and then of course tesla
an existing car company pretty much
followed the exact same blueprint with
the cyber truck i remember the one
famous working prototype doing some fun
laps around new york city you know the
pre-orders climbing into the millions
which again is a few hundred million
dollars of interest-free loans straight
to tesla
still not sure when this thing's gonna
ship though and then of course i did the
thing that i was talking about in the
beginning of the video with the roadster
that was back in 2017 it's been five
years since they showed that car off and
who knows when it's ever gonna ship so
the moral of the story
beware of these companies parading
around
working prototypes of electric cars
while also taking pre-orders with far
away delivery dates or unknown ship
dates just that the combination of these
things you should pay attention to it
i'm still going to check out new
electric cars when they get announced i
want to see what kind of new stuff is
out there
but anytime i see a new eevee
announcement
i'm automatically going to add
a couple years and several thousand
dollars
no matter who it's from okay that's it
for my rant let me know what you guys
think of all these all these new
electric car announcements we've seen
over the past couple years in the
comments section below we'll hang out
there either way that's been it thanks
for watching
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]